Берлінські кадри для Петра Порошенка дуже цінні.
Він негайно публікує фотографії візиту в соціальних мережах.
Анґела Меркель приймає тільки одного з двох кандидатів,
причому того, в якого менший рейтинг.
Це здивувало багато німецьких ЗМІ.
Портал "Шпіґель" відкрито запитує:
чи не є аудієнція Порошенка з Меркель
втручанням у передвиборну боротьбу?
Із цим питанням кореспондент DW звернувся
до офіційного представника уряду ФРН.
Той назвав цю версію "домислом".
Петро Порошенко справді обговорював із Анґелою Меркель
важливі політичні питання, включаючи конфлікт на Донбасі.
Однак німецькі експерти, на відміну від канцлерки,
переконані в передвиборному характері візиту Порошенка в Берлін.
- Це частина стратегії Порошенка: все ж переконати
більшість виборців перед другим туром у тому, що
в Європі з ним рахуються, що саме він -
той президент, який активно сприяє зближенню України з Європою.
Поки Порошенко гостював у Берліні, його конкурент
Володимир Зеленський відправився в Париж
на зустріч із президентом Франції.
Шоумен летів звичайним рейсом-економом,
збираючи додаткові очки. Зустріч же Порошенка і Макрона
була запланована на вечір п'ятниці.
А от Меркель із Зеленським так і не зустрілася.
Однак це не означає, що Берлін відвернувся
від шоумена, кажуть аналітики. Вони впевнені, що
прозахідний курс і реформи в Україні
будуть продовжені в разі перемоги на виборах будь-якого з кандидатів.
- Від президента в Україні залежить менше,
ніж про це думають люди. Його головні компетенції
- зовнішня політика й політика безпеки.
Для економіки же центральне значення мають
парламентські вибори.
Тим часом президент Порошенко йде на все, щоб
скоротити відставання: здає аналізи крові
на алкоголь, визнає помилки, намагається
затаврувати Зеленського як прокремлівського кандидата.
Ось чому йому так важлива була зустріч із Меркель.
Однак берлінські експерти сумніваються, що навіть
прийом у Берліні виведе Порошенка в переможці.